checking for elevated body temps with
edge-enabled cameras
the launch of ibm cloud code engine and
a look at the ibm cloud community
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
last episode i talked about an awesome
way that edge-enabled cameras could help
businesses detect if customers were
wearing their masks properly
and today i want to touch on another way
that this tech can help the world reopen
a little more safely
a very important aspect of a safe and
healthy return to work
is the ability to monitor workers and
customers for elevated body temperatures
real-time ai based video analytics
enable thermal
or infrared cameras at business
entrances to screen body temperatures
when the cameras register a high temp
they generate alerts that allow you to
assess the person for risk
ibm edge application manager places
analytical workloads
with the edge-enabled cameras and the
system sends results to the ibm maximo
worker insights platform
privacy is built right into the
detection process so it doesn't share
any personal identification data
and there are no transmission or
processing costs
to learn more about this tech and other
ways that ibm edge application manager
can contribute to a safe and healthy
return to work
see the blog link below next up i've got
something for all the developers out
there
i'm excited to introduce ibm cloud code
engine
our newest platform for hosting all of
your cloud native workloads
ibm cloud code engine is a fully managed
serverless platform that runs your
containerized workloads
including both interactive http driven
applications
and run to completion batch jobs don't
have a container image
we've got you covered code engine will
take your source code
combine it with a supported runtime
environment and then create and run the
container for you
you don't even have to worry about the
underlying infrastructure
code engine takes care of all the
cluster management including
provisioning
configuring scaling and managing servers
and
depending on the load code engine
automatically scales your containers up
or
down including scaling to zero so you
only pay for the resources you actually
use
seems like a pretty good deal right best
of all it's all free while we're in beta
to get started with code engine see the
links in the description
finally i want to close out this episode
by shining a spotlight on the ibm cloud
community
ibm community is the online platform for
ibm user
and technology enthusiasts who want to
share learn
and do more with ibm products and
associated tech
it offers a constant stream of freshly
updated content including featured blogs
forums for discussion and collaboration
and access to the latest white papers
webcasts presentations and events
created specifically for members
by members there are two main
communities
public cloud and middleware these two
groups boast over 70 000 members
globally
more than 25 topic user groups and
hundreds of forums and educational
webinars
so whether you want to connect with peer
users in your industry
take advantage of exclusive events and
resources or build your online influence
by contributing content
click the link in the description and
join the ibm cloud community today
thanks for joining me today for this
episode of ibm cloudnow if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description of this video and again
please don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and stay up to date on what's
going on in the cloud
now